we just ran from the club with Fabby
Fabiano congratulations what an
impressive Victory and you have
immediately the question from Peter
swedler who just ask how do you do
it you should explain you know I was so
nervous during this game I I can't
explain at some point because I um I've
played a lot of games against Richard
where he out plays me in this sort of
style and uh and also I felt the
pressure of the tournament situation
like do I play for a win but I don't
want to take huge risks of course
because uh the worst thing is to lose uh
and and to miss out on everything but of
course lenier maybe let's say he gets
some winning chances I also have to
watch out for that so I had a lot of
thoughts going through my head